hi I'm Sami I'm one of the contributors
for the Daft open source project and I'm
really excited to present it to you
today
so a little background on us I'm Sami
sidhu I'm the CEO and co-founder of
ventral Computing the company behind aft
I background is in high performance
Computing and machine learning I have a
dozen or so patents of Publications in
the field
and I've worked in self-driving the last
decade working on problems dealing with
image and lidar data handling
um I was a Chief Architect at Deep skill
which was acquired by Tesla and I've
worked out places like lift level 5 and
Toyota and this is jgf yeah so hi I'm
Jay I'm the CTO at eventual Computing I
led a lot of machine learning
infrastructure at freenom which is in
biotech and at lift level 5 where I met
Sami and uh yeah I was a computer
science program at Cornell and now we're
building Daft together yeah
cool so what is Daft our title side said
it's the python distributed data frame
for complex data that's a lot to
unwrangle so let's do it word reward
so python Daft is built for the python
ecosystem
it's it uses native python objects and
functions if you know python then you
the staff will be really easy to pick up
it's distributed
Daft uses partitioning to do outer core
processing on your local machine but it
can easily scale to the cloud on dozens
or hundreds of machines after
Daft is built using the data from
obstruction if you use something like
pandas or polars or dask data frames
then the API will be very familiar Daft
follows a lot of the same principles and
is as easy as easy to use
also Daft is for complex data now what
does that mean at a high level complex
data just anything that's not tabular
things like images video audio
but I really want to dive in deeper and
Define what complex data is
so what's complex data
so I believe that data kind of lies on a
spectrum between primitive and complex
if you've programmed before you're
familiar with the concept of Primitives
these are the atomic building blocks you
use to build your program things like
integers strings floating Point numbers
and Boolean values
oftentimes these are really powerful
Concepts that can represent things like
someone's age or birthday or someone's
name or a constant like pie but we
usually chain them together to form
higher level abstractions things like
objects
um or structures
and in Data Systems we actually combine
these parameters together to make
structures like lead to longitude which
can encode the location on Earth or a
person which can combine a string and a
number to compose someone's name and age
these uh structures are actually more
complex than imperative they are
composed of more Primitives but they
also encode something with semantic
meaning lately longitude encodes a place
on Earth which has certain constraints
and logic that requires that it requires
and a person also has certain
constraints like a person can have a
negative birth year or a name has to be
formatted a certain way
now what about something like an image
how do we think about representing this
one approach could be that we make a
structure and we encode things like the
height and the width and for the data we
can actually just have a sequence of
integer pixel values
so this is a a decent approach but one
downside of this that you know we
couldn't do things like compression or
do things like store things with
different uh image formats
one thing I find really interesting is
that
one thing that goes around is that
images are unstructured data I disagree
with that because eventually look at
this image it's highly structured it has
a height a width and it has a fixed
amount of data pixels it's a tight grid
so why do people call it unstructured
data I think people call complex data
unstructured because like unstructured
data it requires a lot of processing to
extract meaningful value but really we
should be calling this complex data
unstructured to be something more like a
directory full of jsons with different
schemas for each one not something like
an image
so let's go over what makes data complex
number one if it's composed of more
Primitives this image that we show here
of the astronaut the horse can contain
over a million pixels a million
different Primitives
um extracting value out of that we're
generating something like that actually
requires a quite a bit of computational
power and sometimes can require
something like an accelerator like a GPU
it can require domain specific semantics
something like latitude longitude is
only two floats but it can require a lot
of specific Logic for it especially if
you're trying to compute the distance
between two different places on Earth or
do something like an intersection test
the Earth is a sphere for most people
and
um if you want to do logic yes you can
use the curvature of the earth and
sometimes use it for different regions
there's tons of extensions for this but
generally it's it's a little bit more
complex
or it could be hard to represent at
first glance a video is just a sequence
of images but if we didn't represented
it that way we would explode the amount
of data we use oftentimes videos are
represented by codex which are usually
like a sequence of still frames and in
diff frames essentially from that which
means it's great if you want to move
forward in time in a video but if we
want to enable things like random
accessing or move backwards in time in a
video it becomes quite difficult
so if we wanted to do that we would have
to represent data in a way that would
make it easy
cool so now we have to find complex data
let's kind of go over the landscape and
and see what tools we can use
okay if you are only working in
primitive data you're in luck there's
lots of really good tools for that a
common user interface for primitive data
is something like SQL
and if you're using SQL and you want to
do large-scale data analysis you have
things like snowflake Google bigquery
and you know the new and hot ducktv
these are really great at expressing
queries uh if you're doing things like
standard SQL aggregations and data
processing in that regard but once you
need a little bit more flexibility using
an engine that supports user-defined
functions or udfs is really powerful one
engine that I found really powerful is
spark SQL where you can Define
user-defined functions in Python
register it and then call it for SQL
in the example we gave about encoding
Computing the distance between two
points on Earth you can write that as a
python UDF and Spark register it and
then use that in SQL which is really
powerful
if you need more flexibility you have
something like tablet or data frames
which is like pandas which I'm sure many
of you are familiar with and some and
pullers which is like the new and hot
data frame Library
these are really powerful for expressing
compute you can run almost any arbitrary
python function on your data frame but
the part that's limited is the data
types that it can represent you're still
limited to essentially what's supported
by most SQL engines
now if you do know the data that we're
talking about complex images video audio
all the stuff we've been going over
what's kind of the tools you would use
and the answer is you're kind of on your
own and you kind of have to build
something from scratch in the you know
times I've worked in self-driving we've
had to kind of build out bespoke systems
for each application we're targeting you
normally would encode your application
and build your logic using libraries
like pillow numpy some kind of job queue
system and Deploy on infrastructure like
kubernetes for data storage you usually
Define your own protocols and put them
in something like parquet store S3 and
this usually requires a large team to
maintain and build and I think is a huge
uh barrier to entry for a lot of people
to deal into Wrangle complex data
and that's why we both Daft we want to
bridge the gap daf can represent all the
data types that we talked about that are
Primitives things that polars pandas and
postgres can handle but can also unlock
the potential for wrangling complex data
so you can in a single data frame have
things like integers strings uh normal
numbers and also have images video audio
and a single data frame and do
processing on it
so what does that come with it comes
with a familiar data frame interface
if you've used pandas uh that would be
really really easy to pick up we want to
express some typing system we actually
do doubts in a completely lazy logical
plan but that means that as you're
writing dab we can actually infer types
and build a essentially a schema for
every data frame using the composite
types of Primitives and the data types
that you're using natively so if you
make your own data class or your own
python object we can represent that
represent that as a type
we have really powerful python native
udfs if you have your own python objects
and you want to run your own functions
on them you can run them easily on daft
we also support stateful udfs if you
have a machine learning model with state
or you want to use something like
batching in your model and use a GPU you
can express it as a stateful UDF and
deploy it on daft
and finally we're distributed we
leverage partitioning to do out of core
processing on your machine and parallel
processing in the cloud it's a simple
one-line change on your laptop to go
from there to the cloud
and now it's time for a live demo all
right let's do a live demo always fun
um so in this demo we will be going
through a simple example of how you can
use Daft to go through the open images
data set and find the images that are
the most read right we just want like
the reddest images and uh show that
maybe save that and maybe you know we
can relabel it and stuff like that for a
machine learning use case probably
um so let's start off with just defining
this one flag distributed equals false
I'm using in this notebook to run
everything on my local laptop we'll go
through what that means in a bit and
later on we'll revisit this and show how
we can use Daft in a distributed fashion
the cloud so by setting this flag now
distributed equals false okay we can run
this and start loading the images from a
remote storage right so in this case we
actually have all our images saved at
this URL uh somewhere in AWS S3 and all
we have to do is say hey Daft you know
load a data frame from these files and
since we're not running in a distributed
mode we're going to hit this line of
code which will limit the number of rows
to just 100. just for the sake of this
demo so that we have we can process
everything in in a good amount of time
um and so we will print the data frame
and what you'll notice is that daf will
say hey there's no data to display right
now right the data frame hasn't been
materialized and that's because like
Sami said Daft is lazy so until you
actually tell Daft to compute and
materialize your data it's not going to
but what daf can do is that it will
actually already tell you what columns
are in your data so these are all the
columns we have right this is size
column which tells us how large each
image is and then this other name column
will be important because it's the
actual like path the URL to the image
essentially
um and so let's go ahead and just run
some filters on the on the data which is
really common whenever you first Wrangle
a data set you want to you know filter
it just for the data you want and I'm
going to run two filters uh to filter
the size for everything smaller than 300
kilobytes and everything larger than 200
kilobytes right again Gap is lazy so by
running this filter you're not actually
running any computation what you're
doing is you're enqueuing these
operations in a query plan and so we can
view this query plan it's very powerful
you can view it and you can actually see
here that there are these two filters
each one corresponding to these two
commands we just ran right this one does
the filter for everything less than 300
000 this one does a filter for
everything more than 200 000. what
you'll notice is that hey actually doing
these two filters one after another is
really inefficient you have to go
through the data frame twice uh to do
this uh and and it would be much more
efficient if you could combine these
filters and do it in one pass and that's
the good news is that Daft actually has
a really powerful query Optimizer that
will do this optimization for you at
runtime so to view the optimized query
you run the same explain operation with
the show optimized equals true
and now you'll see that there's actually
just one filter Right Daft has kind of a
combined and fused the filter operations
and now it performs both the filtering
for more than 200k and less than 300K in
size so that's really powerful and let's
actually go ahead and run uh this this
plan right now right so the order of
operations in this plant is going to
scan some data it's going to apply the
limit that we defined a limit of 100
rows and then it's going to filter the
data set and so to run this uh data
frame you just call Dot collect that
will materialize your data frame in
memory and run the entire plan and we
will see that we actually only have 16
rows after running the filter and all
these columns here and the sizes are all
now between 200 000 and 300 000 which is
amazing that's exactly what we wanted
and we have this name column which
actually is the only column we need
everything else is kind of just metadata
so let's go ahead and just prune this
data frame down to just the name column
we do that with the F dot select select
the name column and that's show five
rows of the data frame and awesome now
this is the data frame we're going to
work with it's just this name color
cool now let's start talking about
complex data that's what that really
excels at so with this name column what
we want to do now is start pulling
images down from from these uh file
paths right to do that we can first
transform this these strings into URLs
by concatenating this S3 prefix and just
doing a string concat to the name column
that gives us S3 URLs and then now we
can just treat each string as a URL and
call a download method on it and this is
where it gets really powerful because
when you think about it a URL is just a
string but it has a semantic meaning of
pointing out to some remote data that we
want to pull down right so that allows
you to interpret the string as complex
data and download the data so if we
collect the data frame after creating
this new column called image with this
expression we now see that we have bytes
in our column amazing we're now pulling
bytes with a single line of code from
this uh from these URLs right and now
you know the bytes aren't that useful we
need to make Power sent into images so
what we can do is we can define a simple
user defined function or UDF uh in Daft
and and so this function is called bytes
to pill it converts bytes to pill images
and we're going to tell adapt that hey
this function will require two CPUs to
run right this is a resource request we
can also request things such as number
of gpus for example if you're using gpus
and then we'll tell daf that hey this
function returns another returns a pill
image and then the function is super
simple it just iterates through the
bytes column that we're passing in
creates a pilimage and resizes it to 256
by 256 in height and width super simple
function to run a UDF on your your data
frame you just run it on your data
frames column just like this run the
bytes to pill function run by simple UDF
sorry on your image column and we're
just appending back to the same image
column so we're just replacing the bytes
image column now with a pill image and
that's what you get so now we have the
URLs on one side and the images on the
other
cool now let's start doing some magic
and pull out some of the red pixels in
these images to do so I've defined this
magic red detector you don't have to
know how it works just know that it the
magic bit detector will take in an
existing image and it will output a new
image which is a mask of where it thinks
all of the red pixels are and to run
this magic red detector on our on our
column all we need to do is call Dot
apply right this this line says apply my
magic detector on my image column and
create a new column here called grid
mask
so let's run this and beautiful looks
our red mask is working this airplane
like stripes on the wing some chillies
in this dish this red bag is like really
activated
um so now we maybe want to sort by how
many red pixels there are right so again
Define a super simple function to sum up
all the bright pixels in the mask and
then I'm going to sort by this new
column that I've created called the
number of pixels that I read and we're
going to sort it by descending order and
so we'll see that the red bag now is
spanked pretty high
and everything else that doesn't really
have Reds red pixels are kind of like at
the bottom cool so we've just ran you
know on 16 rows locally just on this
data frame and experimented locally what
if now we wanted to run in the cloud and
run on much more data so we can do that
simply by connecting that to a remote
cluster so I'm going to go ahead and
clear all the outputs here and let's
re-run our note book
and now I'm going to switch this flag to
distributor equals true and show you
some of the code that's necessary to
connect after it to a cluster and so
we're using Ray here which is a
distributed computing framework this is
initializing the array cluster which I
have set up already remotely and I have
a proxy locally and in order to tell daf
to use this cluster for execution all
you need to do is call this one line of
code set Runner to Ray and give it the
rate the address to the ray cluster and
now adapt will actually run remotely on
on the ray cluster right so exactly the
same code you call from files you know
we're going to load
um all of the data from our images again
in this case since we're running in a
distributed fashion this flag is true so
we're going to limit our data set to 10
000 rows instead of 100 and we're also
going to re-partition our data set so
that now we have our data frame is
actually 64 partitions that we can now
process in parallel and do things really
efficiently so let's go ahead and all
the code from here is exactly the same
right we're going to go ahead and filter
our data these explain operations and
now we'll collect the filtered data
thing so this is now executing on the 10
000 rows and we'll see that after
filtering we now have 2 000 rows instead
of the 16 that we originally had when we
were running just locally
um and so now same thing filter just uh
we'll we'll just get the mean column
download the URLs and so now this
download operation is running a download
on all 2000 uh URLs and notice how fast
it ran because it's running uh on a
remote cluster with many many more CPU
cores and it can run these partitions in
parallel and so we're gonna go ahead and
load again load the bytes into images
these are now running on on the remote
cluster and the remote cluster now will
also do the magic rear detector for us
so it's running the magic red detector
on all 2000 images
will take a little while to run
and so these are all the images from our
new larger data set so some of the
images are different like this this one
here with like red seats a red car we're
gonna tell Daft now to run the counting
of the pixels on all 2000 and now we'll
sort uh based on the count of web pixels
ignore all these warnings numpy and pill
don't get along for some reason but yeah
now that we have way more images a lot
of the images are actually kind of very
red there's one right here with uh
watermelon on the red background that's
our latest images a reddish image out of
all of our 2000 images these flowers
watermelons looks like watermelons in
general are pretty red
these These are tomatoes and a Ferrari
yeah and so now we have 2 000 images all
sorted by how red they are right and
they're super simple to do in Daft just
by defining all these custom functions
on pill images and that's it for the
demo yeah thank you and
foreign
Daft is a data frame library to kind of
bridge the gap between primitive and
complex data we're we have a data frame
interface we have an expression type
system as you saw that can work with
both types of data and we have powerful
udfs that can extend to do things like
detect Red download URLs
um I guess and whatever else you can
pretty much think about machine learning
models machine learning models uh we're
distributed as you saw you can it's
pretty much a simple line switch to go
from your laptop to the cloud and yeah
um or Daft you can find all of this at
getdaf.io so we hope you guys get Daft
we're hiring for people who have
backgrounds and databases compilers
distributed systems come chat with us
and our emails are right there Sammy and
Jay
adventurecomputing.com thank you thank
you
now I've got to find the how do you stop
sharing and
cool
oh we do have one question in there
Patrick Patrick oh
yeah from Patrick only the resize photos
are stored in memory in the Daft data
frame is that right that's correct so
what we do is we have the bytes stored
in memory and then when you um do the
resize the decompression which gives the
full memory and then the resize the only
the resize memory photos are stored in
memory and then the former bytes are
garbage content yeah and something
really important to note is that let's
say you have two functions and the
function before those in an unresized
pole image and then you run another
function to resize it daf performs uh
these optimizations that will fuse these
two together right so you don't actually
have to materialize the really big
unrecized uh image in the middle because
that is spotted not a few steps and it
also supports outer core so because we
don't have any sorting or anything
beforehand if I only had let's say 100
gigs of ram in my cluster but a terabyte
of images adapt will automatically do it
in Windows and actually store the resize
images in memory uh and spill it over to
disk